thank you so much for that introduction
it's an honor to be here I'm going to be
speaking about data and scholarship and
some of the magnificent developments
made possible in the digital environment
developments that have potential to
change the way scholarship is developed
the way knowledge is used organized and
shared this can create new forms of
scholarly communication and speaks very
much to what Steven mentioned in his
keynote talk about computing back and
the importance of data in this context
I'm going to be talking about data as it
pertains specifically to scholarship and
I'm going to be describing a tool called
our map that can facilitate this kind of
communication so let's think about the
pre-digital time for a while and how
data was connected to scholarship this
is dinner owes encyclopedia from the
1700 I love the Beatles it was bounded
and discreet this could create
challenges for scholarship over the long
haul of course let's go into a little
story about Gregor Mendel the father of
genetics or may be thought of as the
father of peapods who analyzed about
29,000 p pods pea plants to develop his
theory of inheritance dominant and
recessive genes Mendel published his
findings in 1865 they were ignored
another scientist well before his time
some decades later in nineteen hundred
they were rediscovered in some decades
after that in the 1930s a scholar
published an article questioning
Mendel's data saying that it seemed too
good to be true remarkably in the past
50 years there have been over 50
articles exploring issues about Mendel's
data but controversies surrounding the
data can
be resolved because Mendel's notebooks
are missing they were thought to have
been burned so in the pre-digital forum
environment data of course was stored in
analog format data always has been
observed and summarized but it was
stored in vast repositories some of our
great museums the Smithsonian here in
town the museum of natural history of
course there is always a need to store
physical objects the rise of digital
publishing is a game-changer in this
environment we go from these temples of
information that's Trinity library
Dublin absolutely gorgeous housing
information scholarship as bounded and
discreet that's the nature of analog
information as incredible as it can be
we transition to the digital environment
where we have vast repositories of
scholarly articles creating all sorts of
opportunities repositories like JSTOR
part of my organization the rise of
digital publishing has been remarkable
we all know that in the past 20 years
what we've seen in digital publishing
has been astronomical a Association of
American publishers survey found that
ninety-four percent of journal surveyed
are available in digital format over
half of library budgets acquisition
budgets are for e-books so we're dealing
with a new format for scholarship and
that new format enables a different
notion of publishing with an impact on
scholarship that's immeasurable it opens
up an entirely new world for scholarship
we've seen that scholars expand the role
of data in their research as data has
moved as Stephen talked about in his
incredible keynote data has moved from
analog to digital and along that
continuum
than to computable this is really within
that space of between digital and
computable what happens there with
relationships between data and
scholarship scientists are generating
more data not just scientists
everybody's everything is generating
more data and publishing in digital
format creates opportunities for more
dynamic use of data so we can see some
examples of in this post analog
environment where data is not
necessarily lost the kinds of ways in
which data can be repurposed and reused
we're in Washington so we can talk
politics a little bit you may remember a
few years ago Paul Ryan's budget which
posited posited that public high public
debt stifles economic growth that was
based on economic research when those
economists shared their research with
scholars the scholars found a coding
error in the data that led them to
determine that actually the opposite
finding was true that significant public
debt does not stifle growth Nathan
Myhrvold when he is not running
Microsoft or making cookbooks went back
and study paleontology data and
determined that dinosaurs didn't grow
that fast or as fast as had been thought
so what happens when data is not lost
when it persists offers remarkable
opportunities for ongoing conversation
and dialogue this creates a scholarly
record that is not static it becomes
mutable and dynamic very different from
that slide I showed you earlier of the
library with its gorgeous structure and
it's beautiful books but that was static
what this can lead to is a new view of
the scholarly record instead of taking a
top-down approach we can take a
bottom-up
what's a top-down approach a top-down
approach is the article as the entry
point into understanding things and in
the past articles would have included
figures tables charts graphs but those
were disaggregated from the underlying
data what happens when data is connected
to scholarship and the entry point can
become different how does this change
the difference in how information is
collected how it's used how it's created
and how knowledge is created we end up
with a very new very dynamic environment
something that is quite exciting the
scholarly record becomes more dynamic
and less bounded once upon a time
digital artifacts and scholarship were
more or less discrete objects now we're
seeing that the article is evolving into
a multi-part distributed object I'm
going to say that again because it's so
important think of a scholarly article
as a multi-part distributed object the
new article contains building blocks
that consists of text graphics and data
some of these reside in different
repositories they're maintained by
different institutions and employ
different technologies this creates
evolving relationships between the
building blocks that need to be
preserved if you have the article in one
place and the data in another charts
graphs how do these relate to each other
how do we really capitalize on the
wonderful potential of the digital
environment well this creates very
dynamic changes in digital publishing
you know there's greater expectations
for connections between publications and
data and increasingly importance of
collaboration among a number of
stakeholders
formerly maybe could have existed a lot
more independently that includes
publishers data centers preservation
services and a need for tools to serve
these these interests there's a need for
new intermediaries how often have we
heard about that in the digital
environment that even though there might
be content creators even though there
might be you know organizations and
individuals that produce data there's a
need for different types of
intermediaries to connect these and
against even touched on this in his
keynote when he was talking about being
able to compute back and and look at
data and some of the work that Wolfram
is doing so there's a new interest in
not just preserving the publications and
data but actually preserving the
relationship between and among these so
that they don't get lost think about
what data mapping looks like now this is
the linked open data cloud it's a huge
huge data is everywhere how do we
connect find the right place where data
can connect to scholarship so there are
problems with connecting data to
scholarship it's not unusual even for
scholars to put their data on a hard
drive or put it in the University
repository where it isn't really curated
we've heard that word a lot this morning
and it's a very important word in this
context so we've grown accustomed to
being able to read papers with figures
and statistics but being able to
actually get to the underlying data is
quite challenging you know there are
broader systemic challenges for example
funding for research should grant
funders be funding just research or
actually managing the output of research
that's really a shift in thinking about
what the funding goals are
organizational structures historically
there's been a lot of siloing data
management challenges these silos silos
such as the world of faculty versus
administration versus IT the library the
business side of these all of these
areas are stakeholders in data
management and need to figure out ways
to collaborate professional preparation
our scholars being adequately trained in
the importance of data management and
curation priority among researchers
researchers are rewarded for new
research not necessarily for managing
pre-existing research even institutional
mandates the notion of large-scale data
sharing of cumulative sets of research
to advance a larger research agenda is a
relatively new concept it bumps up
against certain institutional
restrictions even like IRB review you
know some some institutions can't hear
certain data some data is subject to
more restrictions there have been a few
efforts to improve data management on an
administrative side on the Office of
Science and Technology Policy I know we
have someone in the room who has been
there too who could speak in greater
detail to this but issued called for fun
funded agencies to have data management
policies the NIH has initiated policy
other other agencies have joined in on
that these efforts have had the desired
effect of focusing and galvanizing the
government educational and private
sector to build an infrastructure for
publishing and data there are some
examples to of efforts the OA I that's
the open archives initiative o re object
reuse and exchange
has developed the concept of resource
Maps you're going to hear that word that
phrase a little bit more in this talk
resource Maps information graphs that
describe aggregations of data and
publications and the relationships
between them the private sector has
proprietary information graphs Google
Amazon and Facebook against even touched
on some of these and it looks like
Wolfram two is developing its own way of
connecting and mapping data to
scholarships to enable computing back
even with these wonderful efforts there
are some limitations you know there are
preservation needs in connection with
those relationships relationships can
change over time so how can that
relationship be preserved and an
understanding of that relationship to be
preserved also the scholarly community
has certain unique requirements that can
be developed that can complement some of
these other efforts so introduce the our
map project this is a collaboration
between the data Conservancy out of
Johns Hopkins and some other
institutions portico which is a digital
preservation service that's a part of
Ithaca the organization I'm affiliated
with and I Triple E it's funded by the
Alfred Sloan foundation the goal of the
our map project is that is to preserve
publications their underlying data and
the relationship of text graphs other
elements that at present reside in
different repositories maintained by
different institutions using different
technologies this project builds on the
work of OA I owe our E and moves forward
in other ways it's expected to be
released in the spring of 2016 there
have been some antecedents to the our
map project a good example is archive
which allowed for authors to submit
articles
archive collaborated with the data
Conservancy also part of our map the
authors could submit papers and their
data could be submitted to the data
Conservancy and then a bi-directional
link established the connection so that
was a great example of enabling
scholarship to connect to data there are
some challenges lack of metadata is a
problem and also preservation issues
preservation of the link itself and
preservation of the data there have been
other projects some of these connect
data to publications some of these are
more focused on simply connecting making
sure that data about different aspects
of publications are understood somebody
we have a speaker here from orchid will
be speaking tomorrow that focuses a lot
on the data about the authors and other
aspects of publishing so there's a lot
of conversation happening now in this
area our map advances the state of the
art in certain specific ways it captures
many to many relationships instead of
that bi-directional link that we saw
with archive the idea is to understand
that it's a very broad and very dynamic
environment and there can be data and
more data and even more data relating to
a certain article preserving the notion
of preserving the connection between the
data and the publications is also very
important so frequently those
connections are lost scholars move to
new institutions repositories forget
that they have certain data the data
isn't curated also the notion that this
is multidisciplinary disciplines have
their own idiosyncrasies they're there
for certain reasons but they also can
make it difficult to have a
comprehensive view and there can be
instances in which data from one
discipline is actually relevant to
another discipline so I'd like to talk a
moment about some practical aspects of
this like what are some of the actual
usage scenarios because ultimate
our map project aims to serve a very
practical function it can have an impact
for scholarly authors it can have an
impact for publishers it can have an
impact for repositories of information
because it will connect publications
data and research and expose and
preserve those connections this can
enable new forms of scholarly
communication research and digital
publishing so take for example an author
submitting a paper to a publisher the
author can submit the data set and also
have the our map tool mint a resource
map remember that term resource map
between the data and the article and
that link will be preserved forever they
can be joined at the hip another example
is a publisher receiving an article
saying gee I wonder what antecedents
there are two this are there other data
sets that we should be aware of the
publisher can look to our map and
determine what the resource maps are two
other data sets that relate to the
article yet another example is a journal
archive portico is a dark archive it
exists to ensure publications are
preserved in the event the publisher
goes out of business when that content
is then triggered so research
publications that may have been dark
archived for a very long time if they
are triggered it might be useful to
understand what some of the newer
developments are what data sets relate
to those publications those don't need
to be lost simply because that article
was sleeping for a long time in a dark
archive another example is replicating
research and the value that brings
imagine seeing a published article and
be able to say huh was that accurate I
mean it's scary for
cures themselves to our publishing but
it allows for much more transparency of
data and opens it up even with the
wonderful prospects of our map there
will be some continuing challenges
funding for data management is always a
challenge also quality of data if
various data sets are going to be mapped
to the to the publish to the publication
how do we know that the quality is good
and also confidentiality again some
institutions if it's involving human
subjects and all there could be
restrictions and issues on how that data
is shared but the main takeaway is that
what we're seeing since the theme of
this conference is the Internet of
Things the notion of the scholarly
article becoming a connected object a
multi-part distributed object with link
connections to its data creating a
vibrant environment for scholarship a
new form of communication which really
sets the stage for the future of
research and publishing so I'll end by
saying I think that what this ultimately
leads to is the end of conclusions
because data can be reviewed data can be
analyzed and reanalyzed and supplemented
and we can end up with this bottom-up
view of scholarship not simply a
top-down view of scholarship thank you